well how did he ban you from the country
made a phone call I'm guessing when you
have that accumulation of wealth like
are you still banned well te technically
I'm not banned technically my Visa cuz I
had an eser which I was always using
when you get an ester you get two years
and you can go in and out as much as you
want and when I was trying to go back
through um they said it was denied so I
went to the Embassy had a conversation
and they literally made up the most
[__] story like it it just wasn't
true and then literally about a month
before I hadn't spoken to said
billionaire for ages he sent me a meme
it was just like a symbol like anime and
it was just like be gone thought be gone
thought and yeah I got banned and
luckily luckily it's not like I didn't
get to America and they didn't kick me
out I I got to England London gwick at
like 6 o'clock in the morning you know
my relationship's on thin ice I'm going
there to save my relationship and it's
like hi are you Georgina Weir yeah your
feet has been revoked I was like oh